peux-tu
les appétits des promoteurs immobiliers
sont décidément effrénée dans un
immeuble du 16e arrondissement de paris
les vieux locataires des derniers des
tâches sont priés de vider les lieux
devant leur résistance le propriétaire
sans hésiter les a privés de l'ascenseur
et la bourse s'en tire bien avec une
baisse
[Musique]
je m'appelle charlie magie et j'aime
bien ici depuis 1953
venir et je m'appelle relève guy joseph
je fais alors qu'un maçon carreleur
j'habite il joue depuis 1960 je
m'appelle marie thérèse baylet épouse
grace qui j'ai 67 ans c'est moi qui fais
les courses lorsque mon mari ni de pain
moi je m'appelle esquiros camille j'ai
79 ans j'habite ici depuis 37 ans avec
ma femme je m'appelle madame esquiros
violette et 73 ans je suis locataire de
cet immeuble depuis 37 ans nous n'avons
jamais eu aucun problème jusqu'à ces
dernières années il y aura bientôt deux
ans qu'une société s'est rendu acquéreur
de cet immeuble
et comme au site et avoir des ennuis ils
ont essayé de nous proposer de l'argent
ou ta o'dowd sur 20 locataires
il ne reste plus que sept
nous restons donc quelques uns sous la
loi de 48 et pour nous influencer
essayer de nous faire vider les lieux
on nous a coupé l'ascenseur en fait nous
sommes privés d'ascenseur depuis dix
mois
que voulez-vous il a qu'une poignée de
vieux ici aux 5ème et 6ème on vend des
bonbons être approprié en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monté six étages canton à mon ange et du
range artificielle et pas quand même
c'est un peu douloureux et voilà et je
souffre d'une angine de poitrine
j'ai de l'artérite dans une jambe l'âme
est très difficile de monter les
escaliers surtout quand il ya six étages
alors ici je reste confinée je regarde
la télévision
mais là oui c'est la détresse page
arrive c'est commence à peser
où ça se gâte
est ce que je vous dis oh moi
[Musique]
non je pense pas dur et oui je vais
rentrer quelles énergies fossiles
pourraient avoir un c'est faux maudit
c'est une injustice flagrante
nous nous sentons prisonniers enfin
vraiment aux tâches
deux de ces gens qui ne pensent qu on
profite c'est une lame se sont pas des
gens il n'a pas pas je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment des hommes peuvent
agir d'un ailleurs on m'a dit vous savez
madame c'est bon pour le coeur de monter
ce qu'ils pensent c'est à se remplir les
poches
c'est tout ce qui compte pour eux les
gens ces deux semaines pas des animaux
parce que les animaux et recueille ils
sont bien mais il s'occupe pas des gens
ils ont rien à faire des jeux tv c'est
du rêve à être arrivé je vais travailler
voilà on n'ira pas ailleurs pour aller
où vous voulez vous connaître
on n'a pas d'argent d'avancé sur l'asie
si c'était un atout de cycle nous avons
aménagé ici il y avait absolument rien
pour faire tout ce que l'on m'a n'ait
travaillé pendant 32 ans
il étouffe et quand j'arrivais en 1966
est un vrai tour d électricité arraché
les fils prodigue pas sauvage voilà ce
qui s'est passé la cuisine pareil le gaz
aussi n'était pas terrible
voilà errecart les lécher les murs
[Applaudissements]
et si pareil pas de chauffage non plus
j'ai tout refait les murs le plafond et
le plancher que j'ai relevé
voilà là aussi j'ai toujours fait le mur
ce n'était pas joli joli
alors c'est sûrement à cause de ça que
nous payons un loyer qui est basée sur
la loi de 48
voilà les toilettes pareil maintenant
avant c'était des chiottes
il y avait une caisse en bois qui a
d'ailleurs affiché le voilà le carrelage
a été refait par moi même aussi
voilà électricité refaite à neuf
pose de choquant pour moi même comme moi
ici c'est mon petit village et je suis
très bien comme ça dépend à 85 ans qu'on
voit même avec 88 francs qu'on peut s'en
aller par ailleurs et trouver un autre
appartement utérin donc je pense qu'elle
va rester là jusqu'à temps que
vient alors dit jeudi le sucre n'est pas
parce que j'ai pas envie de redescendre
mois on fait gaffe eux a lâché qu'elle
puisse pas voilà en aucun cas importés
rédigé en aucun cas se nous oblige à
partir on se fait sauter 52 53
sakho 4
si je me souviens bien 57 depuis que les
senteurs été arrêtés depuis le 22 le
mort sa pêche bien soixante dix mille
vaches et bien bon et si je compte
encore mais ben ça fait bien la moitié
du mont everest que j'ai remonté à
avouer que à 80 corps c'est un monsieur
important dans l'immobilier
il a on n'a rien de temps rasé mon
quartier à la place des maisons il
mettra bientôt des tours de 60 étages
bourré de bureau quand je vois ce
personnage sous son casque de chantier
qui a inspecté son ouvrage je vois zaugg
s à la plage avec son seau et
s'appellent eux et je me dis que depuis
le temps rien n'a changé il fait mieux
the comme un petit enfant sauf que ces
jouets sont un peu plus gros qu'avant il
fait mumuse comme un petit enfant mais
ses pattes et qui c'est qui vivra dedans
[Musique]